Cześć i witaj z powrotem w serii kursów Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Nazywam się Victoria Lipinska i w tym filmie przyjrzymy się, jak reprezentować
dany problem VQE w sposób zrozumiały dla komputera kwantowego.
Zazwyczaj problem chemii kwantowej jest wyrażony w kategoriach energii
układu.
Operator opisujący te energie nazywamy Hamiltonianem.
Najpierw musimy go skwantować.
Czyli wyrazić go w języku chemii kwantowej,
który formalnie nazywamy drugą kwantyzacją.
Jeśli Hamiltonian opisuje oddziaływania fermionów, na przykład
energię elektronów w orbitalach spinowych, mówimy o tym
jako o fermionowym Hamiltonianie i to będzie nasz punkt wyjścia na dziś.
Qubity mają jednak swój własny język.
Operatory w świecie qubitów opisywane są przez operatory Pauliego.
Naszym celem jest więc wyrażenie operatorów fermionowych
w kategoriach operatorów qubitowych.
Istnieje proste odwzorowanie jeden do jednego między
stanami zero i jeden dla fermionów i qubitów.
Odwzorowanie stanów jest więc też proste.
Jednak odwzorowanie operatorów jest nieco bardziej złożone.
Fermionowe Hamiltoniany wyrażane są za pomocą operatorów kreacji i
anihilacji.
Naszym zadaniem jest więc ułatwienie komputerowi kwantowemu zrozumienia
Hamiltonianu.
Użyjemy narzędzi matematycznych, by odwzorować fermionowy Hamiltonian
na qubitowy Hamiltonian z gates.
Innymi słowy, będziemy tłumaczyć między
językiem chemii kwantowej a językiem obliczeń kwantowych.
Wyobraź sobie dwa łańcuchy – jeden z fermionami,
czyli w języku chemii kwantowej.
A drugi z qubitami, czyli w języku obliczeń kwantowych.
Na pierwszy rzut oka odwzorowanie wydaje się proste, prawda?
W obu przypadkach widzimy układy dwupoziomowe.
Dla fermionów mamy albo jeden fermion w stanie,
albo żadnego.
A dla qubitów mamy albo stan 0, albo stan 1.
Jest to jednak bardziej złożone.
Różnica między łańcuchem qubitów a łańcuchem fermionów
jest czymś bardzo fundamentalnym w fizyce: tym, co nazywamy symetrią wymiany.
Dwa fermiony nigdy nie mogą zajmować tego samego stanu.
W łańcuchu qubitów jest jednak zupełnie inaczej.
Dwa qubity mogą być w tym samym stanie,
bo qubit nie jest fermionem.
Musimy teraz znaleźć sposób na tłumaczenie między tymi dwoma łańcuchami.
Już w 1928 roku dwaj badacze, Jordan i Wigner,
pokazali, że operatory fermionowe dla całego łańcucha
można dokładnie przedstawić w kategoriach operatorów qubitowych.
To najprostsze odwzorowanie dla komputera kwantowego.
Można go na przykład użyć do odwzorowania obsadzenia
orbitalu na spin jednego qubitu.
W praktyce takie odwzorowanie Hamiltonianu daje ważoną sumę operatorów Pauliego.
To bardzo ważny fakt, o którym warto pamiętać,
i wrócimy do tego w następnym module, gdzie omówimy
jak variational circuits są wykonywane na komputerze kwantowym.
Powyższe odwzorowanie oznacza, że gdybyśmy mieli na przykład
14 operatorów fermionowych, odwzorujemy problem na 14 qubitów.
Na szczęście istnieją sprytne sposoby na zmniejszenie liczby qubitów
i zużywanie mniejszych zasobów kwantowych, by uzyskać lepszą wydajność od komputera kwantowego.
Zazwyczaj w układzie molekularnym będziemy znać
pewne symetrie fizyczne Hamiltonianu,
na przykład całkowita liczba elektronów jest stała.
Tę informację można wykorzystać do zmniejszenia rozmiaru problemu
bez utraty żadnych istotnych danych.
Tę technikę nazywamy redukcją przestrzeni aktywnej.
Pozwala ona zmniejszyć liczbę zasobów, czyli liczbę qubitów,
przed odwzorowaniem qubitowym, jak transformacja Jordan-Wigner.
Ten krok oblicza efektywny Hamiltonian
i pozwala nam w efekcie używać mniejszej liczby qubitów.
W naszym przykładzie z 14 orbitalami,
ta technika redukuje liczbę qubitów do zaledwie sześciu.
Możemy teraz posunąć się jeszcze dalej z tymi redukcjami.
Możemy użyć różnych odwzorowań,
które są nieco bardziej rozbudowane niż Jordan-Wigner.
Najpopularniejszym przykładem jest odwzorowanie parzystościowe.
Odwzorowanie parzystościowe nie mapuje obsadzenia orbitali na qubity,
lecz parzystość orbitali na pojedyncze qubity.
Nie będziemy tu wchodzić w szczegóły matematyczne,
ale ważne jest to, że odwzorowanie to zawiera dodatkowe
nadmiarowości, które można wykorzystać do usunięcia dwóch kolejnych qubitów.
Zatem nasz przykład z 14 orbitalami redukuje się z 14 qubitów
do 6 qubitów dzięki redukcji przestrzeni aktywnej, a następnie do 4 qubitów
dzięki redukcji dwóch qubitów w odwzorowaniu parzystościowym.
Wspomnijmy krótko o jeszcze jednej transformacji.
Innym powszechnie stosowanym odwzorowaniem między
reprezentacją fermionową a qubitową jest transformacja Bravyi-Kitaev.
Transformacja Bravyi-Kitaev używa qubitów do kodowania informacji
zarówno o liczbie obsadzenia, jak i parzystości stanu kwantowego.
Transformacja Bravyi-Kitaev łączy informacje o liczbie obsadzenia i parzystości
dla bazy orbitali molekularnych o rozmiarze N,
gdzie ponownie używanych jest N qubitów.
Jednak informacje przechowywane w każdym qubicie
różnią się teraz w zależności od tego, którym qubit jest.
Mianowicie, gdy indeks qubitu jest parzysty,
przechowuje on liczbę obsadzenia odpowiedniego
orbitalu, tak jak w odwzorowaniu Jordan-Wigner.
Gdy indeks qubitu jest nieparzysty, qubit przechowuje parzystość pewnego
zbioru liczb obsadzenia. Transformacja Bravyi-Kitaev jest najbardziej wydajna,
gdy liczba qubitów zbliża się do potęgi dwójki.
Odwzorowanie Bravyi-Kitaev łączy zalety Jordan-Wigner
i transformacji parzystościowej.
Zmniejsza liczbę qubitów, na które działa każdy człon Hamiltonianu,
co jest ważne dla symulacji kwantowych, gdyż człony
działające na dużą liczbę qubitów w Hamiltonianie
wymagają dłuższych circuits do ich symulacji.
Oznacza to, że głębokość circuit
jest zmniejszona dzięki transformacji Bravyi-Kitaev i ogólnie
możemy uzyskać lepsze wyniki na sprzęcie.
To ulepszenie w stosunku do transformacji Jordan-Wigner,
która daje Hamiltonian qubitowy rzędu N.
W tym filmie zbadaliśmy więc metody odwzorowania
fermionowego Hamiltonianu na qubitowy Hamiltonian.
W następnym zobaczymy, jak najlepiej wybrać stan
i variational form lub circuit.
Do zobaczenia.